to noon I feel a word of congratulations
is in order your last breakout session
for it
for this year so well Doug you've made
it right so this would be a fairly
leisurely session so I'll try to keep a
quiet high level we'll run to about 4550
minutes so I'll leave plenty of time for
questions at the end but the major
question we'll look to answer today is
how do we as API developers choose
between grukk UL g PRC and rest so to
get to that answer we're actually going
to do quite a few things so we're going
to go through first of all a tour of API
styles and we'll look at them over time
due to do if my clicker was working
so API Styles overtime and what we're
going to do from here is get an idea of
how the thinking in our industry has
evolved we're actually gonna stare at
about 20-30 years ago and then look at
all the major technologies that we've
seen along the time we're gonna see
where they're different and actually
quite where there's a lot of similarity
between them and we're then gonna take a
bit of a pivot and we're going to look
at how we actually make architectural
decisions so we're gonna look at the
properties with rural water systems to
exposure a beer and then we'll look at
how we make decisions or implement
constraints which will then yield those
properties as well so very much an
outside-in view to it so with that
context set within going to look at a
few the conversations that are happening
in the API industry today and take some
of their rather blankets black-and-white
statements and peel back the covers and
then see how they actually really way up
so add a little bit of nuance to each
one of those points so we're gonna
allowing us to make a more informed
decision such that if you look to choose
one of these API still Styles maybe in
your company or I gave maybe in your own
time that you'll be able to make a more
informed decision and finally with that
knowledge where they gonna look at some
sample scenarios and then choose based
on that maybe what's the simplest of the
most appropriate one to choose so before
all that a little bit about myself so my
name is Rob Crowley I am the head of
engineering for a company called Vista
Technology so automated fare collections
very similar to the oyster care that you
might be aware of in London and previous
till as I was a principal consultant for
Telstra purple in Australia so pretty
much my entire career has been in
designing operating and running
distributed system so API is are very
close to my hat I'm also the
co-organizers for DDD Perth the largest
IT conference in Western Australia so
about 800 attendees every year so that's
grown beautifully and I'm also available
on the socials at Rob D Crowley so if
there's any questions that come up
throughout this session or if you'd like
to get in contact maybe you've taken one
of the ideas in love with it please
reach out I'd be absolutely delighted to
help so I'd like to share a little bit
about why I'm giving this talk today and
I really have to confess
it's a slightly selfish motivation
because my Twitter timeline is an
absolute tire fire you see what I joined
Twitter I'm I started reading about the
same time when my interest in rest
started and I followed my caimans in
Eric wild and I'll host of other
luminaries in the API space and it was
very much all this rest orientated
content that I was getting it everything
was going grand for about four or five
years until 2015 and graphic you all got
released I started following a whole
host of new people it turns out these
groups don't agree a lot so suddenly I
would have one tweet that would come out
and say you should really do this and
then 17 18 different rebuttals that
would come out and say don't touch it
and in fact there's many of the
conversations that we'll look at today
as well so maybe one little example
so back in 25th of May last year my
birthday I saw this tweet it's 2019 you
should learn grati well I said
absolutely why don't I share the love so
they're ago retweeted 15 seconds later
Aaron Powell he's actually one of my
good friends came back it's just fancy
OData well this is a little bit of a
playful exchange often the ones that I
see are quite close-minded and again as
a as a community I really want us to be
able to learn and keep our minds open
and it's not actually it's not just on
Twitter but it's also blog posts so this
came out in 2017 and it's basically
declaring rest as being defunct it's
calling it the new soak that it's
obsolete but at the same time we have
other blog posts that are saying rest
api czar rest in peace and everything
you know that building from now on
should be great q well which is it
little bit confronting for me because
i've spent 10 years of my life building
rest api there's suddenly old and
information defunct and not valuable
anymore surely not but there's also this
I got a strange sense of deja vu when I
was reading some of these these articles
and history has a strange way of
repeating itself and I actually think
we've been here before so if you're a
2017 there let's wind the clock back a
little bit more back to 2010 and in this
case Roy fielding had just released his
dissertation rest was really on vogue
and we were calling so
to date and that rest was gonna replace
everything about soap another article
from about the same time so soap is
officially dead long live arrests so
there's very many similarities here so
what can we draw from this
so if soap is dead and rest is the new
soap does that make graph QL the new
rest surely not
but yes you see graph QL is indeed the
new rest
paraquad I've never actually seen pair
two but I'm sure it'll be fantastic but
the probable a lot of these articles
have is they're very Pro one side and
they're not balanced so again when we
want to take it to where companies or
make a decision ourselves I often feel
we can end up making a choice of the
technology itself and not the properties
or the characteristics that is imbibes
and how it then matches to the problem
that we have at hand so I guess what can
we learn from that so we could be rather
whimsically just say maybe we just don't
like XML and we get on with us but I
think we'd be missing a rather large
point there because really I feel the
the issue is deeper seeded I feel many
of our API consumers so the people
consuming our API s
using them every day reading our
documentation calling them are
unsatisfied and frustrated and I think
that's a far deeper seeded problem so
how can we build products that truly
give the experience we wish and I repeat
our community is small so again let's
not get hung up on one technology or
another let's work together and see of
all the tools that we have available to
us how can we work and choose the most
effective one so it's all sounds of a
dreamy doesn't it so imagine if there
were no protocols no hypermedia Hills to
die on no media types wouldn't that be a
wonderful world we wouldn't have to
argue about technology at all we'd all
just get on beautifully unfortunately
that's not the way that API is work API
is we need to have a contract between
two parties we need to have protocols
and specifications
such the two parties that are otherwise
separated can have a conversation and
understand the semantics and the syntax
of the messages passed across the wire
there's no escape for this so we will
always be locked and looking at wire
formats semantic constructs have our
messages so we need to do a way that we
can understand them better and actually
see some of the similarities between
them so to that let's look at API
technologies over time and we'll start
back in 1991 with a middleware called
core map and this was an RPC framework
so remote procedure calls so that's a
phrase coined by Bruce Nelson and one of
the oldest styles of distributed
computing interactions and in fact this
was actually deemed at the time going to
be the future of e-commerce on the web
however it soon fell out of favor for
XML of all things then in 1993 remote
data access got released and that's a
way of querying data from a database
over a network interface so if you're
thinking from there
it kind of sounds like a query interface
and it absolutely is so the client thin
defining the shape of the data that it
was you got sent to the server the
server would then process it pass the
query retrieve the data send it back to
the client in 1998 we got a formal
specification for RPC released by
Microsoft and that was based on XML
sapphire we had a strug contract for how
to build these distributed systems
however one year later again from
Microsoft
so Doug box one of the authors of the
four tenets of SOA released soap and
soap again very much at RPC based and we
had wisdom as the interface of the
contract force and this really formed
the vast majority of the api's that
would built in this early 2000 phase so
in 2000 we did have Roy fielding
released his rest dissertation which
imagine if we could build a POS that
were in harmony with the web and we had
this little bit of two and fourth for
the next three to four years whirling
around pretty much in parallel sometimes
soap starting to fade a little bit into
the background and rest API is becoming
a bit more popular mainly by companies
like Twitter or Facebook that were
released
public api's at the time in 2005 we see
Jason starting to take over from XML and
in 2007 we see Oh data so under the
moniker of a better way to rest so
released by Microsoft again touching the
same style as remote data access so
allowing clients a huge amount of
flexibility in the queries that they
shaped so instead of a canonical URI as
the uniform interface in rest would
define we could have clients defining
any shape of data they want so
incredibly flexible so empowering the
client rather than having it defined by
the server and that's a paradigm that
was really embraced by graph tol in 2015
as well where they very much have
mutations for the rights which are
actually very much like our PC and then
query api's for the read side so it's
actually not that different to many of
the other techniques that we've been
using before and then in 2016 we got the
latest incarnation of an RPC framework
so G RPC and very much a focus on
performance and code generation but
again very much building on what we saw
with JSON RPC and XML RPC before us so
that's the technologies itself let's
have a look at what was happening in the
industry at that point in time so when
we were building API is back in the 230
mm s it was very much for one provider
and one consumer and they were very
direct stovepipe integrations and this
changed quite a bit
with web 2.0 in 2010 when we were
started to build api's for many
consumers so instead of specialized for
one consumer one partner you could then
have many consumers so falling more into
a conformist model if you follow Eric
Evans and that was really a massive
change so instead of trying to optimize
for one use case we actually wanted very
flexible api's and I think we'll see
that continuing to evolve as we build
richer more complex systems as well and
truly embrace cloud native I think we'll
see many too many interactions so far
more service server-to-server lattices
of api's building and again if you I
mentioned a couple of names as we go
through like zenyk Zdenek who talks
quite a lot about this next eva loose
of api's so across all this time and
different techniques men still classify
all of these technologies and we put
them in buckets like this so query API
is where we want to empower our clients
to retrieve the data that want or we're
favoring flexibility we have flat file
API was very popular in the early 2000
so EDI or electronic data interchange so
still absolutely perfect maybe if you
have a flat file extract from your
financial system and you need to do
month end report again it doesn't need
to be real-time it is absolutely still a
valid form of API and if this is batch
and a synchronous that this is the
streaming api's are absolutely real time
so you can think about serving video or
maybe stop price updates but you think a
lot of very rapid potentially
bi-directional communication across the
wire as well
we have RPC api's so again G RPC XML RPC
with very much calls and again with the
RPC paradigm it's one component calling
another component across a distributed
network but almost pretending that that
distributed network is not there so
we're treating that as a facade across
it whereas what web api is we spit up a
HTTP client we embrace the web and this
web api is really where the majority of
our REST API or HTTP endpoint api's
would land so I guess if the the overall
angle of this talk is to say which is
the best API style I think I have to
confess now and it might be difficult to
last talk and the last day to suddenly
be told that there is no single best API
style computing has had right so there
is always a best style for your problem
at hand and that's the key thing that I
want to take away from today don't
choose a technology and fit a problem to
it let's look at the shape of the
characteristics of your system and then
we could work backwards what would that
process look like so we can get some
guidance here again from Roy fielding
the man behind rest and he says the
properties of this obvious system are
induced by the set of constraints within
an architecture so rest itself defines a
set of constraint
some one of them is the uniform
interface constraint so with that it
says that any resource in a restful api
can be accessed through a canonical you
arrived and then what you can do with it
is denn defined by the HTTP method the
HTTP methods or verbs that are that are
associated with that particular resource
and what we get as a property of that
constraint is simplicity that you have a
uniform interface and irrespective of
the API you know how to interact with it
however there's a trade-off to it
because we're putting in an abstraction
that could potentially cost us
efficiency or performance so again
there's not always pluses to these we
have to trade off some of the
constraints but it's not just about the
architecture themselves there's many
other types of constraints that we need
to factor into the systems that we're
building
so there's business constraints so who
are you building for are you building to
a customer who has their own release
schedule that you can't align to maybe
you don't have controller influence over
us maybe there's specific capabilities
so if your customer is only capable of
consuming flat files
well good luck building a G RPC API for
them so again you might have certain
constraints that are defined by that or
performance constraint scalability
constraints that we can also have
technical constraints so again how is
this system going to operate how is it
going to be robust or resilience where
do you trade-off between the two so
again looking ass viii fallacies of
distributed computing thinking again how
do we build that characteristics
potentially looks out native
architecture into the api's we build so
again very different if you were
deploying to your own data centers and
then finally we have the most
interesting ones all the human factors
around our systems so if we're building
products then how do we keep these
products healthy and sustainable over
time so we have to factor in things like
the knowledge and expertise of the teams
so unless your teams know HTTP really
well then it can be challenging to build
a truly effective restful api because
what it does leverage all of the
semantics of the underlying protocol
there's the rub you need to understand
it inside and out and
could be quite a steep learning curve
you also have to think about how you own
those systems so Conway's law an
observation that says the systems we
build with mirror them in communication
patterns within an organization so how
do we build our teams that align them to
the products that we build so once we
take all of those constraints be it
business technical or socio technical we
can then see all of the properties that
will be imbued in the system both around
the ecosystem so all of the operational
concerns but also then of the software
system itself and what I do whenever I'm
designing a new system I always start
here I always that what are the
properties that my system needs to have
how is it going to need to be security
scalability what are other features that
I need to do and then once you have a
clear idea of the characteristics of
your system they're looking at what
constraints you can apply that will
yield those properties so how might we
be able to do that in a broader sense so
again we have a bit of guidance here
that says well there's no best
architectural style that's suitable for
every problem we can compare
architectural stars by looking at the
properties and again looking at the
constraints the particular architectural
style will apply and this was actually
my original premise for today's talk so
I was a little bit disappointed to find
out about ten minutes into my research
that someone's actually already done it
so this gentleman called Zdenek Nemec
who gave the keynote at Nordic API is at
the end of 2018 has done a very good
comparison between rest and graph QL in
a low level of detail that takes all of
the of the constraints that are defined
by rest itself and then additional
operational constraints and now also
then complies it and contrast it with
graph UL and this is graph UL of the
ecosystem about 18 months ago so some
things have changed but you're still
going to broad viewer a comparison
between the two so again from that I
will share this and all of the slides
and resources afterwards so no need to
take photos as we go through but we're
going to do something a little bit
different then and we're going to go
back and look at some of the
conversations that are happening
the industry we're going to take these
myths or blanket statements then we're
actually gonna ask a little bit more
questions and we're gonna go that little
bit deeper and see is this actually true
or to what degree so first of all let's
go back to this article that I
referenced in the first couple of slides
that declared rest api is a rest in
peace api's long live graph QL so
clearly the author here saw no more
value in rest api's and we have another
article at the same time that said graph
UL would do to rest what Jason did to
XML is it really that clear-cut so again
let's look at the thinking of the
paradigms on the pinning graph QL so on
the query side it is very much remote
data access and on the right side it is
RPC so actually really nothing
incredibly revolutionary there and it's
actually got a fair amount of HTTP or or
rest semantics thrown in as well and
then let's have a look at G RPC itself
so again a little bit different but G
RPC ties itself specifically to HTTP 2
while graph QL declares itself as
protocol agnostic in a similar way to
graph QL G RPC always uses HTTP 2 as the
transport and he HTTP 2 is actually very
specific here so I'd hate you to be what
dot X it has to be 2 as a minimum and
the reason for that is that it leverages
a lot of the streaming capabilities of
HT db2 for its functionality on the
transport and schema side it uses
protocol buffers or protobuf and that is
both for the schema so the wisdom you
could think in a soap API or an open API
ramble or API blueprints contract in a
restful api and then also as the data
exchange format over the wire and g RPC
is incredibly flexible for the types of
interaction that support between a
client and the server so it supports
traditional request response so one
request from the client of one response
back also known as a unary operation
but also more complex interactions such
as service streaming so one request from
the client can yield multiple responses
from the server we also have the inverse
that the client could stream multiple
updates to the server and then be only
get a single response back or we could
have bi-directional streaming as well so
again G RPC is wonderful for real-time
interactions between api's where you
have data changing very quickly you need
to have synchronous interactions or
integrations between them but if we look
at rest it's quite different again so if
G RPC and graph QL are really data over
HTTP or data over the wire rest is a
state machine over HTTP or a workflow
and this is a really key point and when
I talk about a state machine what I'm
really looking at is that word
hypermedia so again the bit of always
kind of throws people out if you're
looking at the Richardson maturity model
it's this thing up at layer 3 but it's
actually not that far at a concept if we
where it's actually Everywhere's the
underlying paradigm of the web so if you
just look at this really basic HTML page
we have hyper media controls here and
the fact we have three of them first of
all we have an image tag and the
semantics of an image tag so whatever
resource is referenced by this URL when
we dereference it it will take the
contents of that and put it in the align
space we have an anchor tag that says
when you dereference that link you will
then be navigated to that page we have a
form which says when we submit it it
will take the data that we've captured
in that form is send it to the server so
are these these are all affordances
which have been sent by the server which
then have well-understood semantics of
the client so in the same way we could
have a a restful response where we can
provide links to the client and the
client could then use the link relation
that would follow that linked is a
terrible where could it go next so if
you have an approval process so you
might put in an order and I might then
go to a pending State
invite them be approved when you've
taken payment and finally shipped and at
any point you control the next
navigations of valid state transitions
for us so anywhere where I'm thinking
that there is a flow and I want to be
able to then tie down the transitions
between that rest is a wonderful choice
for that and since as I mentioned quite
a bit about hypermedia I really have to
say this next line is that rest does
require hate EOS so hypermedia is the
engine of application state and I feel
that this is quite an important point
and I don't mean it to be
confrontational apologize if it does but
I feel a lot of the pain a lot of the
backlash that we're seeing about restful
api is our rest dish
api's is that we've taken some of the
parts of arrest and then other parts are
a bit difficult or maybe we haven't been
able to implement adequately for a
number of reasons and it delivers a
suboptimal experience and I feel that's
a lot of the tension that we sort of see
you the community right there
so I would really implore you don't
build rest assure I'm firmly of the
opinion that from many api's if for
whatever reason you can't make the use
case force or the knowledge within the
team or the client you could actually
get a much better result by either
building it in an RPC style or a graph
QL style so for our less effort and get
a better outcome for us and that's
actually okay because again it's not we
shouldn't start by saying I want to
build a G RPC API and work backwards
it's just saying okay with all the
constraints that I have what's the best
outcome that could have so and if your
API is mostly actions so an example of
this could be the slack API it's an RPC
API it's heavily action based and a lot
again the tension with REST API zhe's
where we have an action orientated
interface and we're trying to squidge it
into a restful URL so we end up with
this resource slash increment or those
sort of actions that you spend a lot of
time bytes chellie about URL structures
and yeah I don't really feel as that
valuable but if however your API is
mostly prod
and you're manipulating related
resources or there is a workflow then
rest is a wonderful choice and in fact
if there is one person you should read a
lot of content from one effects someone
who I've taken quite a bit of content
for their blog post is actually Phil
sturgeon so he could take a lot from he
he writes a blog post called a Piz won't
hate and why he's got a lot of very
strong opinions and a lot of things
there's a lot of experience behind it so
I thoroughly encouraged you to follow
Phil and this is a again just a proving
that there's even the creators of these
of these technologies don't see those
being perfect for all use cases this is
lee byron i like what are the creations
of graph QL and he says that graph QL is
a wonderful choice for Clyde to server
interactions but he doesn't really see
the value of it for server-to-server
communications so very much where you
have a client that has or maybe multiple
clients with different data needs
that's wonderful cuz we're empowering
the client to select the data that it
needs but for server-to-server calls gr
pc or even rest to be a fair better
choice so API Styles they address
different problem spaces if we're
building rest dish api's whether it be
for internally within your team or two
customers consider whether you could get
a better outcome for less effort with
exploring graph QL or RPC and I'm not
saying that they are better I'm just
saying that to build a REST API requires
a high level of experience a dedication
and you often don't see the payoff in a
short time but it's really being able to
evolve over decades is where the power
of rests comes in and that might not be
the shape of your problem at all so
consider that and G OPC is wonderful for
synchronous communications between
internal services this to sports many
different interaction bottles you get a
huge amount of flexibility there so with
other statement I saw that was being
passed around quite a bit and this one
still comes up is graph QL breaks
caching
but what kind of caging surely not all
caching because if we look at caching
there's actually many kinds we can
either cash in the client so that could
be your browser cache we could cache on
the server side also known as
application casing or we can have
Network Asian or intermediary caging so
again case boxes that might sit between
the client and the server so let's take
a look at that
so with HTTP caching we can have these
intermediate casing proxies so you can
think squid our varnish
however with graph QL and G RPC while we
absolutely can still do service
education so retrieve something from the
database may be sticking in Redis and
then send it back to the client or on
the client side we can still have in the
case of graph QL a denormalize client
cache or you could store it in the
browser cache but you cannot do the
intermediary caching proxy and that's
for a number of reasons not only in
graft you're generally uses posts which
are cashable but why are intermediate
asian proxies important that if we could
still get a lot of the benefit from the
server side of the client and it really
comes down to proximity to the client so
what the speed of light is fast about
300,000 kilometers per second it is not
infinitely fast particularly if you're
going over copper wire so we're going
with the refractive index jobs Wally so
again if you can get your data closer to
the client they will get it more quickly
so again from a performance perspective
very valuable
you could also then localize the data
for a number of clients prevent more
expensive calls coming back into your
network as well so how are we start
trying to achieve this support for
intermediary proxy caches with graph QL
Lin and there's been a bit of a shift in
the community over the last year about
it and instead of using posts and pretty
much using HTTP as a as a dumb pipe
there's no kind of champion by Apollo in
the in the node space or one of the
providers they're allowing you to use
queries with an HTTP GET request and
also using persisted queries which are
again queries
precomputed and exists on the server so
instead of having to pass large queries
over the wire you can send it ID then
have a hydration of the server but this
is not part of a standard so this is
still very much things that have emerged
from various area of the community which
is a bit of a shame because that's
actually one of the big power of graph
UL that you had a specification for
graph QL which removed a lot of the
ambiguity or the challenges that people
were building with rest which was more
of an architectural style and there was
no specification which we could
implement there is however no graph Q
well specification for HTTP so again
there's still a big lack there's still a
big gap there so many of the cases for
problems that have actually been solved
by the rest community number of years
ago decades ago we're still solving them
today in graph QL so there's still a lot
of bite shedding that's happening in the
community another thing to consider as
well is whether your API is
authenticated so whether it's open or
whether against you will have an
authorization header with either a
session cookie or a bearer token or some
other form of identity or personalized
data in there because what we should be
aware of there is that intermediary
caches will not cache authenticated
traffic by default so again if all of
your content is fairly real-time and
tied to a specific identity then that
changes your landscape particularly as
well and actually intermediary occasions
might be a concern for you at all okay
so we've already got a little bit of
nuance so breaks caching but there's
three different types of caching do all
of them apply to me maybe not and
there's another thing that you should be
aware of as well is they're more
customizable your API is generally the
less cashable it will be so in the case
of a REST API where we have a uniform
interface we might have slash users
slash one and we'll get a very good case
record for that because the second we
retrieved that record there's nothing
else I could do with it so the cased
version whether it be for expiration
based or
etags you can generally be served to
other users as well as other clients
however the second we start adding query
parameters to it so maybe being able to
select a subset of fields or put an
order or audit again we're creating a
unique identity there and we're reducing
the number or the likelihood of someone
else making that same request
and now imagine with graphically well
where every client can make any query
that they want so that's a huge level of
level of power that you're giving to
your clients so again the Keysha bility
of that will decline so the more
customizable you make your API again
just consider that you will actually be
losing or complicating your life on the
caching side again so everything's a
trade-off
so actually you might be thinking
actually for the API building no Casey
is it that important for me at all so
maybe I actually dead veer towards one
option or the other so the takeaways are
occasionally is that there are many
different types of caching and they
apply to different scenarios so highly
customizable API is where the clients
are afforded a huge amount of
flexibility in the data they request
they benefit less if Network ation is
valuable to you that absolutely looking
at a restful api could be a really good
choice because you will be able to get
data more easily to the age and best
practices are absolutely still emerging
for graph QL and G RPC in this space as
I mentioned before there still a lot of
the communities are still relatively
immature in comparison to rest so there
is still quite a lot of bike sharing
that happens in the area this is one of
my favorites REST API czar inefficient
what do we do with this like how can you
respond to it and I think what we really
have to start looking at is what was
rest for like rest was never about
efficiency there was never its goal so
we were looking to build systems that
could evolve over decades so the
client-server architecture where each
could evolve independently so we were
looking for longevity and reduced quite
coupling and in fact many of the
decisions that were
the architectural constraints of arrest
absolutely went against short-term
efficiency right so that's a very
deliberate choice for long-term
flexibility and evolution but that's not
to say that when we say they're
inefficient that that we should be
conflated with that they're not
performance because there's absolutely
things that we could do with this and in
fact http/2 has removed a lot of the
pain that might have been associated
with previous rest api is usually htb
would not X but what are some of the
major issues that we could see what rest
api is so we can either over fetch so if
we have many different types of clients
maybe a web client or a wearable or
watch those clients can generally
display varying amounts of data but if
you only have one representation then
you might be sending way too much data
to one client and then just sending
slower requests maybe using up their
available bad with maybe their data
allowance on the other side we could be
under fetching which could typically
result in I'm gonna retrieve the master
record and then for each one of its
children I have to dereference the
children independently often known as
the M plus one problem but there are
techniques that we could do to tackle
these so for over fetching we can use
sparse field sets so allow the client to
specify the individual fields that at
once or maybe feel groupings so again
while there's no standard around this
there's a number of options that you
have but effectively allowing the
clients to say I don't what all of us
just give me a subset of the
representation and to avoid many road
trips we can look at compare documents
and compound documents are really the
main aspect of some of the hyper media
types such as JSON API or how hyper-v
the application language that were quite
popular like five six years ago as well
and they were really looking to mitigate
a lot of the issues that we had with
HTTP what Onix api's and this was really
one of the first things where graph
Kewell came to the community and says
irrespective of the shape of the data
that your client requires you could
retrieve all of it at exactly one
round-trip to the server and this was
seen as a massive boon so instead of all
these individual
Quest's we can now create one request
have a process on the server and go back
to the client
doesn't that sound brilliant what we
have inadvertently done though is now
tied a response to the client to the
slowest piece of data we've coupled all
of those individual requests so if we
have some data that could be retrieved
really quickly for the client maybe just
the domaine layout data elements and
then we have some more expensive
computed fields all of that data will
need to be available on the server
before the client sees anything so as
people actually started building api's
and I got stuck this myself with graph
QL and we started getting them into
production we actually saw there was a
lot of effort needs to be invested in
tuning your queries and actually then
moving some of the computed items out
from larger queries and actually making
them separate items themselves so that
we were reducing the volatility of those
requests and again where there's a will
there's a way the community thought okay
well what happens if I could then mark
certain elements as being deferred which
could then be sent back to the client as
a HTTP patch and then the servic then
look at all of those items have finally
stitch them up it adds a lot of
complexity and what we should really be
thinking at this stage is shouldn't
really be this complicated where's that
simplicity that we really want is
irrelevant thinking about that simple
customer experience and if we really
look at all of these compound documents
it was really a result of hahdve 1x
where to establish a connection at the
TCP level was very expensive so we had
window scaling we had handshakes
likewise at the TLS level we had to
establish a new connection so we had to
have the server hello again and that
takes a lot of time to not only
establish the connection but also to
scale up the bandwidth on that
connection so establishing a new
connection for every request was very
expensive and then you could also look
at techniques like the main sharing as
well but we were generally looking to
get around the hacks or the miss or the
limitations of the underlying protocol
well if I'd hate you to be result
resolves a huge amount of these because
we can
multiplex streams over a single
connection so you can have one long libs
connection and then many requests that
go over it so you avoid all of the
hassles of again having to create the
TCP connection and scariest and again
doing the TLS handshake as well it's not
only that there's also another feature
called
server push and what this allows the
server to do is to push resources or
representations to the client without
actually having the client ask for them
so what you could do from here is if the
client was requesting users maybe from
there that you could also proactively
push a number of the child records to
the server as well and from here you
allowing this you're allowing the server
to take a lot more control over how it
can optimize the sending of traffic to
the clients out of fact one of the big
goals of this was actually to have
service optimize the loading of web
pages but we found their preload or pre
fresh links were actually a lot more
effective on the browser space but
there's open source libraries such as
volcano which has been released last
year that now allows clients to send
additional link headers in the request
which the server will then push back to
the client asynchronously sort when it
needs and it will be available in the
server in the cache or the HTTP
connection so it sounds wonderful this
is something that I do expect will
become more popular over time but
there's still a fair amount of profiling
that we need to do on server push I in
the links as well I have included a link
to that library called volcano but it's
an interesting way where as API
developers we can then look at different
ways of serving resources to the client
so performance so with HTTP one the cost
of a handshake was really high and in
fact it was multiple had shakes that we
were doing them very frequently and we
created a lot of a lot of hacks or
workarounds for that typically compound
documents but when we made compound
documents we ruined the case ability of
those requests again because again they
were only as cacheable as the most
volatile piece of data
Noah HTTP - we can send all those
individual requests
back to the client without having to
create new connections so we can do it a
lot more effectively and because we can
still do it in a more granular sense we
still get a very high case ability from
it so it's actually a win-win it's
beautiful
and server push creates new
possibilities again toward potentially
profiling the use of our API so we're
seeing traffic patterns where clients
generally have the set of interactions
and again having that data ready for
when they use them and in fact gar PC
heavily uses HTTP to full stop and in
fact we will talk a little bit about G
RPC web which you might have heard in
some of the Blazer talks this this
conference as well and that's for
streaming methods again so one too many
requests either originated from the
server or the client or in some cases
both directions this is another great
one so graph UL eliminates the need for
versioning so graph view or we don't
need a version or a POS anymore it's a
bit odd because we never had to version
our api's it was always a strategy it
was never a requirement so why we would
version our api's it was a strategy to
handle breaking changes where you would
change the contract on the server and
you wanted to insulate a client from
that effect so then you have make a
breaking change create a new version
that the client could decide when they
want to adopt that new version so
absolutely a strategy but there's other
ways of handing of handling evolving
capabilities and from there it's
graceful evolution and this is really
what has been promoted in the rest space
for quite a number of years in the web
as well that web page is gracefully
evolved in the same way we can build our
api's with non breaking changes and in
my opinion graceful evolution should
always be the goal so where possible
supporting multiple different versions
of an API as a provider can get very
expensive very quickly and complicates
the landscape so not only from a client
perspective but also from a server
perspective you could simplify your life
a lot if you
choose graceful evolution as your
strategy however it does take discipline
so some of the implications of it is
that we can't add new required inputs to
an operation we can't remove outputs or
make them optional because again we
could be breaking your dependency from
the client we can change the type of a
field so if it was a string we can turn
it to a number and we should also be
following the robustness principle or
pastels law so being incredibly broad in
what we accept but incredibly suspect
with what we send so again being
well-behaved citizens and this takes
discipline but what it takes discipline
on the server side you can not treat it
in isolation and another massive call
out is you cannot over communicate with
your users so even if you are going to
make a change don't rely on at sunset or
at deprecation headers on your API
responses and expect your clients to
understand that change is gonna be
coming send a bulletin update them with
change requests let them know a number
of buds out particularly that works
where we build a lot of partner a POS so
for system integrators but also
internally as well and having a regular
caters where we could discuss API
changes has reduced a lot of the
friction around timing those so if I
spoke about the server previously
there's a lot that the clients can do as
well to be well-behaved citizens as well
so if you're consuming an API and you
only need three of those fields don't
break if the server includes an
additional fields that you're not
interested in don't break if the server
sends the fields at a slightly different
order so don't take that response and
serialize it directly into a class and
this tolerant reader pattern is actually
defined American Fowler's book
enterprise integration patterns and it
provides a lot of guidance about when
you're consuming api's how do you make
sure that you can do it in a robust way
and in fact there's a number of other
patterns of that book as well that can
provide great insight into building
resilient integrations between systems
but if we do need to make a change and
you want to deprecate a certain feature
how we communicate that so I've already
mentioned about deprecation and sunset
headers on the response graph QL
actually comes with an inbuilt feature
around this and it's called deprecations
where I can mark a certain field as
saying this will soon be removed and
because graph QL you know exactly what
fields or what data every client needs
you can create a map of who would be
interested or who's in this field and
who should I inform if I'm going to
change it and that sounds wonderful in
fact this was something that was really
excited about because I kind of expected
I'd be able to then have really targeted
conversations with a subset of my my
users and say this fields gonna be
removed are you ok with that can we work
out with the timing but unfortunately
when your API use reaches a certain
level of scale or a certain number of
users it's kind of observed in Hiram's
law everybody depends on something so
you're always have uses that require at
least one of the fields but there's also
implicit dependencies as well so
behavioral systems as well or behavioral
functions in it and that's not always
something that you might document in
your API so you have to be really
careful when you're thinking about
evolving your API that were not just
thinking about contractual changes but
there could also be behavioral changes
in your API switch clients have a
dependency on as well so it becomes a
lot more complicated than simply looking
for a deprecation tag and in fact in
many cases if you're looking to do a
migration to a new service or a new
version sometimes you have to deal with
bug for bug compatibility because you
can control for those clients even if it
doesn't behave exactly as it was a rigid
documented that was the expectation the
client now has so if you're doing any
refactoring of existing systems so again
dealing with legacy codes by by Michael
feathers provides a lot of guidance
around how to deal with these
integrations and breaking out separate
components but the biggest thing we can
do about Libre engine we're leveraging
this is about defining the interfaces so
making systems available starts by
getting the inter
faces right and if we don't do a fair
amount of upfront design that we aired a
lot of those change requests sort of
landscapes we were making breaking
changes for clients so the biggest thing
that I could advise around this is using
a contract first design approach
so what might that look like so in graph
QL that's your schema in GRP see that's
a protocol buffer and in a REST API you
have a whole plethora of choices so you
can have swagger now known as open API
ramble blueprints and number of others
but starting with a common contract that
can then be developed in parallel maybe
by different teams of building a client
maybe actually building out the API
implementation and because you have a
contract is very easy to mock against
that contract as well because you have
that shared interface and then when both
of them are ready that could be
integrated and then the loop can
continue again and we found again by
starting with the contract it was very
easy to evolve that I'll have shared
design sessions between the consumers
and the producers rather than having to
write code and that feedback loop BK
blog or a Bo odorous so again be able to
create a vibe but where it's really easy
to change and update that behavior
quickly we felt a door for the long run
so versioning it is a technique to
manage breaking changes it should be a
last resource it shouldn't be your first
option only use it where absolutely
necessary prefer gracefully evolution
absolutely not a substitute for the
communicate with your users that is the
absolute biggest thing about managing
changes in your API and it doesn't
protect users from depending on app
listed behavior as well so sometimes
it's not just about the interface
changes another one we came across was
domain modeling is purely a rest concern
so if I'm using any other style I don't
really have to worry about it and that's
so not true if you do that you're gonna
have design issues from day one so
always start with your users in mind so
both G RPC and rest start with an
outside-in approach the server defines
the shape of the operations or the
queries and then you start building the
mouth graph QL allows you to take a
slightly different approach to this so
if you were bill
you weren't quite sure about the
interaction patterns of your clients you
could actually get a little bit of a
benefit with graph gol at this because
graph QL delays the responsible moment
of identifying your query needs to
actually profiling those queries so with
graph to you well I don't actually
define individual endpoints or
operations to call rather I define a
graph of data and each query then maps
to a subsection or tree of that graph so
we're not optimizing for an individual
use case but the risk you pay for not
putting that approach is again having a
higher cost or complexity about
profiling those queries later but again
it's a good tactic to deal with
uncertainty or if you've got to have
multiple consumers each with very
different needs so API design is
absolutely table stakes irrespective of
the style both rest and G are PCP follow
it outside an approach where you have to
defy the operations of the interface
graph QL is different and lesson can let
you deal with uncertainty in a slightly
different way and it really allows you
to then see how users are actually
executing against the graph at runtime
but again there's a hair at risk in
there too so if that's all the myths
that we looked at let's now take a quick
look in the eight or so minutes that we
have left across some sample scenarios
and given what we've seen about
architectural decisions and a few of the
blanket statements that we've got made
let's see if we can land on appropriate
technologies just think it's so you're
thinking in terms of some of the use
cases when you go back to your offices
next week okay so first up we might have
the absolute simplest thing we could do
just at the application webform so it
might be for applied to buy a ticket or
something like that or buy a ticket for
an event I don't see personally why you
would use anything other than rest for
this
I see many teams building restful
building graph QL api's from very simple
things like this but here all we're
doing is taking a certain amount of data
it's a right operation and they're
sending it back to the client unless you
have wildly varying data querying
requirements
I think there's simpler options forward
as well and in fact again I thought I
think we'll see
this is the year that a lot of
malcontents will start growing with
graph gol API is where we've built them
maybe not for the appropriate use cases
that were being burned by trying to
cheat or operate them or the overhead of
the inherent complexity of them so
really understand about what's the
simplest API approach that you could
have here problem at hand another case
that comes up quite a bit particularly
what being worth of a client's who have
built highly granular services sometimes
called micro services and then looking
at how do you actually take that
impedance mismatch a very granular set
of api's here that versus what a client
needs an SBA and this is typically where
we were put in and a aggregate API or
maybe a back-end for front-end where we
can aggregate a lot of the calls and
then send it back to the client and in
fact this is a place where graph QL
absolutely shines because it allows you
to connect data from many different data
sources so it could be a relational
database could be a graph could be a
file graph URL is absolutely agnostic of
the data source and that allows each one
of the clients to then query the data
that it needs and it gets optimized over
the wire so in many cases we see putting
in graph QR as a layer over the existing
set of services to optimize the delivery
to different digital channels as being a
very sweet spot for graph QL and
typically graph QL can be brought in
after teams have felt pain with an
endpoint driven approach where maybe we
didn't profile or define those endpoints
appropriately so we're having a lot of
over/under fetching happening with those
clients and that's actually a pattern
that we follow did quite a number of our
consulting engagements as well and that
also allows you to then create an
abstraction point where you can start
refactoring some of these
implementations I get without affecting
the client so we go decoupling change so
if that was web what about mobile so if
we want to have a BFF so again a
back-end for front-end and in this
architecture the API is actually owned
by the client team and this is something
I've been playing with quite a bit
myself and I'm actually thinking that G
RPC is actually a wonderful fit for this
particularly in the native space which
I'll explain it a little bit because
what this guy lets you do is get one
protocol
end-to-end in your stack so you can have
one place where you share all of your
proto files and then be able to do all
of the code generation off all those
files themselves and the beauty with a
native mobile app as well as they can
you can use HTTP to end to end whereas
there's an issue with G RPC and that's
in the browser space where the browser's
don't expose an API to the sufficient
level of granularity to ensure that you
use HTTP 2 so we can't actually use pure
G RPC in a browser or if you're in a web
component or a blazer app as well so
there's a couple of techniques we could
do but particularly in the native space
G RPC is are really those fit so for
micro services so again I'm not going to
say in this particular case any
event-based micro services so if you're
looking for synchronous coupling so
again more orchestration style then
again I see a huge amount of value in G
RPC and the co jet particularly if you
haven't standardized your runtimes so if
you're looking at having maybe some of
your API was written to java summin
summin c share some in c++ any other
language having approached having a
protocol file a pro tip off the fighter
there'd be able to co-chaired the client
to the server side and keep them in sync
that way is a very powerful pattern but
what can we do then about G RPC in a web
app and there's actually a companion
protocol to GRP see it's called G RPC
web and it is actually quite different
because the purpose of G RPC web is to
enable you to create compatible G RPC
traffic's over HTTP 1x so that's really
the goal so for environments where you
can't guarantee HTTP 2 then you can use
G RPC web so what does this look like so
typically you would have a browser or in
fact it could be a service side like
like an app service in a zoo because
that doesn't let you support HTTP - yes
either so you can actually think of it
as an outbound call from an app service
as well and then you could start with
the RPC traffic do your a geo PC web
traffic go
- 1 . XO then typically you would wrote
that through a proxy so it could be
Envoy which is the data plane side care
in sto and that will then convert the
HTTP 1 dot x gr PC web traffic to true G
RPC traffic but you are looking at
introducing a separate G RPC proxy so
two days ago James Luton King released
quite an exciting post saying that in
dotnet they've actually supported
actually no created an experimental
package that allows you to issue G RPC
web requests directly and have them host
and have them served by a server without
an intermediary proxy so that means that
you could have at SBA or you could have
a blazer web component app make a call
to an azure app service over G RPC
compliant traffic or b8g RPC web traffic
and what this lets us do is get the
common protocol buff driven workflow and
then when the work to complete G RPC
supports for app services become
available it could be transparent to
change so it allows you to adopt some of
these techniques now this is absolutely
still an experiment but I'm quite
excited about the separate piece of
infrastructure being removed there is a
got Schuette RPC web though is that you
lose a couple of the interaction types
so bi-directional streaming and client
streaming and no longer options you can
still do you two recalls or you can
still do service streaming but you don't
get the bit of options ok so what have
we covered in today's talk so we started
by looking at API technologies over time
and we actually saw there's a huge
amount of similarities between them
where a lot of it is remote data access
and then some form of RPC on the right
so they're actually a lot of the
arguments are a lot of the discussions
that are happening in the industry are
actually about what's different not
what's the same
from there we dug into a norm of the
conversations that are happening in the
industry and we peeled back a little bit
more data so that if you're looking
to choose one of these technologies that
you can get past that first it will
never work because and be able to have
better conversations around this finally
we took a very brief view at some of the
major use cases that I could see in my
experience where I used what are these
technologies or not but please I really
see a successful talk as being a sales
pitch for your future time so if I've
encouraged you to look into one of these
technologies or learn a little bit more
or have an effective conversation with
your teammates that that would
absolutely be a wonderful outcome for me
so thank you so much for your time I do
realize there was a a lot of competition
as for all slots so I really appreciate
your attendance thank you